monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues le ministre de la
santé vient de répondre sur le volet
santé publique de ma question qui
concerne également la filière cbd qui a
commencé 2022 sous de sombres auspices
avec cet arrêté gouvernemental du 31
décembre qui interdit en france la vente
aux consommateurs de fleurs ou de faits
bruts ou sous toute forme seul ou
mélangés il a pourtant permis des
avancées comme ça a été évoqué ça
représente néanmoins un coup d'arrêt
brutal pour tout un écosystème où se
croisent grand producteur de chanvre
comme dans mon département dans l'aube
petits paysans qui ont diversifié leurs
productions et jeunes entrepreneurs qui
ont pris des risques pour ouvrir la
boutique ce marché c'est un milliard
d'euros des millions de consommateurs
comme le rappelait mon collègue des
milliers d'emplois ces français ne sont
pas accrocs cbd bien d'être ce n'est pas
parce qu'ils prennent une tisane au cbd
le soir qui vont devenir des junkies
l'argument sanitaire peine donc à
convaincre
la consommation d'anxiolytiques qui a
explosé avec la crise sanitaire concerne
plus d'un français sur quatre voilà sans
doute un vrai sujet de santé publique
qui mérite l'attention
la position de la cour de justice de
l'union européenne était pourtant très
clair aligné sur la doctrine de l'om est
avec des taux de thc inférieure à 0 3 %
le cbd n'est pas un stupéfiant donc une
régulation est nécessaire mais d'autres
moyens existent est pourquoi ne pas
avoir renforcé le processus de contrôle
des producteurs les chanvriers qui sont
soumis à un haut niveau d'exigence
prouve comme c'est le cas dans l'aube
que c'est possible et la france reste le
premier producteur européen
le feuilleton juridique français
continuent pendant ce temps nos voisins
européens accélèrent nous serons bientôt
inonder de produits issus de pays qui ne
devise pas sur les feuilles et les
fleurs comme nous en avons seul le grand
art madame la ministre quelle est votre
stratégie pour soutenir l'écosystème
après l'envoi d'un drôle de signal
pour vous répondre
[Musique]
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice vannini paoli gaza à la suite
d'une commission d'une décision de la
cour de justice de l'union européenne
les autorités françaises ont révisé la
réglementation applicable à la culture
l'importation et l'utilisation du
chanvre par un arrêté du 30 décembre
2021 ce nouveau cadre réglementaire je
veux le préciser s'il maintient au
niveau de protection des consommateurs
est prêt et préserve notre politique
ambitieuse de lutte contre les trafics
de stupéfiants comme l'a très bien
expliqué le ministre véran permet aussi
de sécuriser le développement économique
de nouvelles activités liées à la
culture et à la production d'extraits et
la commercialisation de produits qui en
intègre simplement on en précise les
règles cet arrêté c'est donc une chance
pour la filière qui est aujourd'hui la
première européenne et qui dispose de
grands donneurs d'ordres intéressés pour
ses produits dans la cosmétique par
exemple ou dans l'agroalimentaire c'est
un marché qui représente 700 millions
d'euros et 15000 emplois
l'interdiction que vous mentionnez elles
portent que sur les fleurs et les
feuilles qui ne peuvent être récoltées
importé utilisé que pour une production
industrielle et à les justifier je vais
pas revenir sur les arguments qui ont
été développés par le ministre de la
santé c'est un produit psychoactif dans
les feuilles et les fleurs bien malin
qui est capable au premier coup d'oeil
de mesurer le taux de thc et bien malin
aussi qui s'effeuillent et ses fleurs
elles ont tendance à plus concentré si
pour des raisons donc de protection du
consommateur et de lutte contre les
stupéfiants que cette réglementation
était prise je veux préciser deux choses
la première chose c'est que la
commission européenne a validé cette
cette réglementation donc il n'y a pas
je dirais de retour en arrière par
rapport à la décision de la cour de
justice européenne la deuxième chose
vous avez on ne mentionner que se
passe-t-il par rapport à la concurrence
d'autres pays il nous tenons une
position au niveau française pour
précisément avoir une réglementation qui
soit commune à l'ensemble des pays
européens ce qui permettrait de répondre
à votre préoccupation tv youtube
[Musique]